before I actually start the story I need
to read to you I had a when I was in you
12 one of the modules I did for
sweetening it mustard in unum English
with speeches so instead of a text
lecture distribution dusty so you say is
that hot or voted or whatever rag that's
right best smelling ever right polish is
a politician yeah always
but those crazy polish they read the
Apple polls did you notice anyway uh we
got twelve speeches so species like
Socrates intensity Matt Luther King jr.
sorry and sighs anyway I am a speaker
not not the holiday Bob Schwartz not the
whole thing
um I just hated from JFK I'm going to
read to you just a small section okay
which which has has nothing and
everything to do with the the story to
tell but I'll just give you a heads up
on any his speech this is speech she
gave of University called Rice
University in 1962 it's actually called
rice is isin Condoleezza Rice like as a
so named kind of anyway she's right all
the university in America I named after
people showed up at Harvard he gave this
speech in 1962 in the context of the
Apollo program those videos with your
polymer rivers face yeah okay so the
Polynesian food hahahaha
more specifically we're going to drink
be born the sky going to certain part of
face cheese many waiting for entries
right so um this is this is a speech it
has a support reference in it which
because it's nice attitude or make no
sense to you okay so I've tried to
update that hard with your rich father
the original will be like woohoo but
hopefully this will make sense to you so
let me reach out to parents in a group
he's trying to justify the Apollo
program there is this strife no
prejudice no national conflict in outer
space
as yet it hasn't a hostile to us hostile
to us all its conquest deserves the best
of all mankind and its opportunity the
peaceful cooperation may never come
again but why some say
the moon why choose this as our goal and
they may we'll ask why climb the highest
mountain
why 35 years ago fly the Atlantic
why does Manley play the wristers we
choose to go to the moon ha ha ha
we choose to go to the moon in this
decade and do the other things not
because they are easy but because they
are hard because that goal will serve to
organize and measure the best of our
energies and skills because that
challenge is one that we are willing to
accept one we are unwilling to postpone
and one which we intend to win and the
others too
ok so yeah hopefully make sense later
now what this is coming under this idea
is areas under curse that's kind of
being something of organisms ok a
mathematician to be fascinated by the
idea area for a long time like it's one
of the most enduring and useful kinds of
problems are there how big is something
ok and even though it's a simple idea
time taken to them ox NOx whatever it is
under the curve we can ask what the
curve is under the area ah doesn't sense
me I know but you're the same sense that
does not make ah the idea area you know
it's a system like this whoa we cannot
even know it's very simple right it
leads to weird kinds of I believe is
like you know if this is a circle of
radius one right the idea of have you
work out this area or this thing well
first thing your work out circumference
which are introduced you to is weird
transcendental number and then the area
involves that number so just might be a
very simple idea right which is what is
area it's just the length x bar
right or-or-or height times equip if you
like a simple idea but it leaves us our
most profound sort of concepts that we
understand in the whole world
okay now in terms of areas shapes like
circles or triangles or you know let's
say quadrilaterals for other kinds of
polygons or codes we're really good at
working out this period right we can
chop and dice it up and everything comes
back to this step this definition even
trained was by the way like base x - 1 -
it's because it's half of the rectangle
that has the second baseman hood we're
really good at working out these areas
okay so in some ways you could say these
are kind of like man may shapes shapes
that we make okay but nature and
particularly on the kinds of processes
that happen in nature has a really good
way of taking all of our sophisticated
methods and knowledge and I'm really
bring it down to science now the reason
why I say that is because nature has all
kinds of areas in it than to fire these
kinds of shapes that we are very good at
calculating ok so something simple
something simple like say you take a
hose okay and you point it in the air
turn it on okay and if it's not exactly
vertical you know the worn up will make
this check now what shape is it now it's
a parabola which is interesting by the
way it's not a problem because it looks
like a parabola there are the shapes
like I didn't bring one with me because
I'm you can if you can find other shapes
right which look like which look like
parabolas this is at least to a certain
point followed I should undo this thing
I'm going back to where it was before if
you take any kind of length that's
flexible and you let it hang under its
own way at some point it's you know if I
if you can imagine you that's just one
thing it looks like a prowler right
looks like the vertex of another but
it's not it's a different kind of shape
entirely the relations yes it has a name
but we'll explain later
um it's a parabola I can prove it
through laws of motion okay now the area
under this shape cool you can dice it up
into anything like these I mean you get
close okay but you can't get don't get
exactly right and it's not the only kind
of show you think about a population or
um you know radioactive decay which
would be the opposite way okay this kind
of area is exactly the same now these
are very very simple ideas right it's
motion under gravity or the growth of a
population
simple my clearly something but it
defies our understanding of area okay
now some of you may we'll ask
although chairs like these are not these
are not even geometric shapes they're
this is like a it's a function right so
who cares about the area underneath it
right twitch I think JFK would answer
well why do you choose to try and work
out an area like this because the
Soviets will do it because we'll lose
the Cold War because it's it's an
interesting for them why not
it's challenging it's it's why should
such a simple shape to find the simple
rules that we already know okay so
there's my not much okay not American I
am a German mathematician and his name
was that i'm bernhard riemann now I'm
probably pronouncing that
but remembers a kind of guy in fact
you'll find him in his picture in our
corridor somewhere I don't I didn't go
check where exactly one during the time
but Raymond
he was pretty smart I looked at this and
he said in the eighteen hundreds I think
he said what this is a challenge I think
I can do something with this okay yeah
let's just take this exponential right
we get rid of this area buddies now
I'm going to go down so he said the very
very most basic idea of what area is
okay and we said before the area is you
know what if we say height times width
of a rectangle that's the basic idea
where and he said I can't get exactly
but you get pretty close if I take this
thing and I dice it up into a bunch of
rectangles okay
now you can do it multiple you know
different ways but here's one way okay
so for instance those are those are true
pieces but we did he said look if I if I
take all of these rectangles okay and
this is um this is called the on the
right triangle right rectangle way I'll
show you left way using other science
Lenin's burger is left um he said if I
take the area of all of these rectangles
that'll get pretty clutch right and the
more rectangles I take the closer oh
yeah right so he said no how do I get
this out later um he said I can get a
pretty close approximation now he wanted
to express you know what he was actually
doing okay so he said look I've got one
big thing okay one be here and I'm
approximating it by taking the sum of a
whole bunch of small areas
okay so we have language and notation
for describing songs of things right so
you'd say look this is the sum of now
some of what how would you express it
okay um well how many having a rectangle
on it will add a new okay can you maybe
you can make it as few or as many as you
might right so let's say I don't know
I'm sorry found any cool off let's let's
start from one okay let's start from
once okay is my dummy variable I'm gonna
have it there in a second and let's end
up whatever Trey rectangles do what
let's just say n rectangles okay so in
this case and would be one two three
four five six seven eight nine okay I'm
sorry go from one tonight now what what
am I actually adding up that's the thing
that goes in here okay
well each of these parts of the Sun
right is a it's a height times width
times width now what defines the height
of this thing this is this is some
function okay well at each point the
height is defined by whatever the
function is now I think I said it was
like me to Mexico did you like to the X
or three weeks or something like that
okay but just for the sake of art that
argument let's just leave it as any kind
of function which we can't work out
areas nice and new before okay so the
height at each point will be f of
something okay whatever you know these
points that we decide higher okay so
what I'm going to call them is you know
this is like my first point so I'll call
that x1 call that 1 X 2 and X 3 and so
on and I guess in this case I'd be able
to like X gnomes okay so if that point
is x1 then the height is f of X 1 and f
of X 2 and so on okay so they're from 1
2 3 4 5 and so on I'm going to use this
K business okay so it's excellent
okay does this make sense is it kicking
with what we did yesterday so every time
I go up this thing is changing we're
gonna get a different height okay now
what's the other part of area height
times width okay now I just defined each
with to be the same it kind of makes
sense to me you don't have to but I'm
just going to leave that as is don't you
okay I could call it something else text
which caught something else but it'll do
for now right so your point 10 years
that's a height that's a weird
and this thing is take the take the sum
of of all the business